there is this overall sense of
uncertainty and anxiety we can expect a
sharp recession the question isn't if a
recession is coming the question is how
bad it will be we don't have a president
we do not know how long it will take the
extent of the downturn depends on the
development of the epidemic the only
thing I can compare to really is not a
financial process but to a world war
it really is like everybody's packed up
and headed off to war where is everyone
this is crazy
in a regular recession economic activity
force a normal recession is not so bad
but at the moment we have acquired it's
a different situation
it's a collapse in both demand and
supply because we can no longer produce
output the supply chain has been
shattered by the coronavirus so it means
people lose their jobs they therefore
demand Falls as well and people from no
longer fulfill their needs to pay their
mortgages their rince economists like to
give recessions a letter a V signifies a
sharp brief decline followed by a
rebound au takes a lot longer than a
v-shaped recession W is a double-dip
recession l is a plunge that stays down
low for a long time I
that's worst of all that's free for
we hope that it will be a v-shape
recession don't we all but that wasn't
the result of a survey of chief
economists while again 30 percent
thought that this would be a sort of
v-shape there was a good 30 percent that
were completely uncertain and a good 5
to 10 percent that actually were
thinking this is going to be an l-shape
this is going to take a very long time
on our side position to strike down we
have to have a collapse in production
simply because this disease doesn't care
about the fact that we're in industrial
species it simply sees us as a species
of a host and hosting this outbreak has
delivered us the fastest deepest
economic shock in history central banks
and governments are throwing trillions
of the pandemic they say whatever it
takes for as long as it takes
but not everyone agrees so how
successful have government's been in
containing this we had a financial
crisis is not really was solved very
eurozone crisis this one really was
solved and now we have the virus causing
another crisis and we see clearly our
strategy of the past 30 years of solving
all problems and the economy by having
cheaper money and more credit and more
loans it's coming to an end
there isn't a belief that there is
coordination between fiscal and monetary
policy despite the very large sums that
are being talked about that there isn't
that coordination at the international
level between various governments of the
nature that we saw in 2008 a global
problem needs a global approach but this
whole pandemic has been about panic it
didn't have to be that way with not had
a virus that has been this transmissible
and this deadly since the Spanish flu
[Music]
that was in 1918 during the end of the
First World War to 1919 1920 at that
stage we did not have the iPhone being
produced in 30 separate countries maybe
the system was a very short supply
chains even though it was handled very
badly
it was localized to a level that simply
doesn't apply this time around so we
should have been sitting at production
of distribution systems to cope with it
and we constructed this economy which is
so massively interdependent at a very
very fragile way commodity flaws are
necessary to produce output they assess
and to add to it we have a little of
private debt which is three to four
times the level that applied back at the
end of the first world war and that
means that people are going to be going
bankrupt the World Economic Forum says
employers it spoke to weren't ready for
this either less than ten percent had
ever thought about pandemics as part of
their current risk scenarios and less
than 50 percent had ever experimented
with even part of their teams working
remotely
but so many people have died while we
experiment with quarantine
[Music]
they've been mass layoffs I don't know
what's going to happen to me
and the effects of the corona virus
could be felt for decades well it could
split the society forever it could
create even sharper inequalities drive
the wedge between rich and poor a
massive increase in homelessness
indebtedness social conflicts I see a
much angrier electorate and a much more
frustrated public about this but also
public that recognizes the need to move
away from globalization to go back to
localized production and we will see
measures on a macroeconomic level which
have been unthinkable before I could
imagine we will see a world of more
government intervention high inflation
rates higher interest rates down the
road and where we see more of an open
financing of governments by the central
banks and that's a community front world
and the world we had before we have to
reconsider the entire economic system
maybe there's too much let's say too
much of a good thing with respect to
globalization this is a wake-up call
that technology and digitalization of
the economy can help us but we are
fragile and we are very vulnerable in
this respect it will take time to
recover from that really very deep
severe economic crisis so back into self
isolation for me
looks like I'll be doing a lot more home
office and reading a heap more books
just hope those economists aren't right
about everything
[Music]
you